I'd such a great time curating the music  for 2k15 am honored that we would be  allowed to have such an eclectic  of songs just stuff that feels good and  I feel like is motivational in a lot of  ways a couple interesting curveballs in  there too I think the common denominator  and in the song selection would have to  do with a particularly feeling you know  the chords are like take you somewhere  or a lyric or melody takes you somewhere  or the drum pattern does something you  know songs that have some sort of you  know ken aesthetic appeal you know where  you're not just hearing something but  you feel some part of the song most of  the people who are on that list have  been a direct and indirect influence on  my music so that list is like very dear  to as dear to me and it's all so dear to  my team because these are those are  songs that moved us as people  you